I was talking to some journalists and I
said to them do you realize what's been
bubbling up in this country and what's
coming next I was like it's almost easy
for them ah because I was like you're a
couple white people like the lines being
drawn are easy at this appreciate that
was getting raided I think this is where
it was maybe it was somewhere else you
hear someone shot shouting shoot the
white people over and over again I
almost only want to say it yeah it's in
the vitsin it's in the videos that are
going viral
Wow I was in Milwaukee in 2017 was that
I think I'm amazing in 2016 and uh oh
yeah I was we were still living in Miami
at the time oh yeah so I went to
Milwaukee and while I was there because
it was some dude you know he got killed
and it was a black lives matter protest
they were shouting things about getting
the white people an eighteen-year-old
white kid got shot in the neck
and so I filmed this I was standing feet
from the police when an armored
personnel carrier carrier pulled up I
saw this I we heard the gunshots I saw
this kid 18 year old white kid was not
involved in anything someone shot him in
the neck some dude it was it was a black
dude picked him up and carried him into
a house trying to save his life they
call I guess they called for help an
armored truck truck pulls up and a bunch
of SWAT cops get come out with their
rifles and they were I don't know the
formation is called but they're all
standing in a circle as they move and so
every you know every direction is
covered they go up to the house the kid
comes outside he's holding a napkin on
his like a napkin on his neck because
he's bleeding and the cops run up and
I'm standing right there and they pick
him up and they rush him into the APC
and take him out Wow that was it for me
I was like they are they've they have
said it
they said they were targeting white
people yeah and I was like it's just
it's not safe I was like I'm not you
know so I made a video about it and it
it may it pissed off like basically the
entire left and I don't care I don't
care if you're pissed off yeah like I
didn't make this video to be like you
know some kind of shock moment yeah it
actually happened and and and I had fans
I didn't say fans but like subscribers
who follow my news coverage and I'm like
this is why I'm leaving and I won't be
covering us anymore and people were like
sorry to hear it man and I was like
if your perceivably white yeah then it
is a serious risk to your safety to be
here because they've talked like I'm
sorry man when I see an 18 year old kid
unrelated not in the protest just
minding his own business gets shot in
the neck yeah um I draw the line
somewhere you know I don't talk about
this often but I my uncle got murdered
by a group of black men he got shot in
the chest you know you know why cuz they
assumed he had money they said give me
the money he said I don't have it I
don't have anything he wasn't rich you
know he's not it's not a rich family and
he got shot and killed and this is a you
know it's like I don't talk about it
often but it's like it happens all the
directions
I don't hate black people now I know you
know there's probably young kids in
trouble probably influenced by its
chicken life no this was in Florida
actually Wow and it's like okay does
that is that gonna change is that is
that gonna make me want to hate all
black people no I know it's it's an
incident that happened it's terrible I
miss him
he was an amazing man but it happens
both ways it all happens the craziest
thing about this is that you you know at
that moment you're describing would make
a lot of people racist I'm sure in it
and it's not right and doesn't change
the problems doesn't fix anything and
it's it's some criminals you know but
look at what's happening right now in
Minneapolis and they don't see it the
same way you know they're they were what
were they yelling outside a CNN no no no
something about anything else
was it not it was a different clip it
was like F the white people or whatever
and then there was the clip from the
place where they were like shoot the
white people and and you've seen all of
this stuff it's been happening dude you
know it's been on Twitter this is why
okay so this is the story I'm trying to
tell you when I had these journalists
and I was hanging out with them I said
have you been paying attention to what
they're saying on social media about
white people use you tell me it's a joke
okay but I've been on the ground and I
watched a kid get shot in the neck I
know it's not yeah
they say they tweet these things and
they mean it and I and I don't like the
racial tensions I don't like the stoking
of fears and I don't like any of that
stuff
yep
and it's and it's and it's obviously a
small faction of people big enough to
make to make an impact where you
actually have now mainstream journalists
saying these things and it's okay and
this is the escalation of violence we
saw coming when they punched Richard
Spencer in the face in DC and I as well
as many other people were like that was
wrong we I certainly don't like the guys
opinions yeah but he was just a dude
standing on a street corner and someone
clocked him all of his mainstream
journalists what did they say they
laughed about it they made it go viral
there was they were sharing the videos
they were remaking the videos haha this
is funny this is funny this is funny no
house ID I said do you know what happens
when you when you when you do that you
get 500 people showing up in
Charlottesville now saying we you know
they want revenge and then you you get
that horrifying moment you know you
don't understand escalation begets
escalation so if you want to go around
punching people that's the last thing we
need to happen you make everything worse
you know that's what scares me about
this the weird thing about all this
Minneapolis stuff is that but the
Conservatives aren't necessarily backing
the cops for the most part they're like
you just enforced a bunch of
unconstitutional orders you think I'm
gonna stand next to you now why you know
after after months of doing that right
yeah up suppress like oppressing us like
and not only that but I mean the killing
of George Floyd was was just insane and
so now agreed on a principals level you
got Sean Hannity being like nom and the
dude was kneeing that guy's neck three
minutes after he lost his pulse I don't
to be careful about what I say here but
according to medical medical examiner
the medical report the dude would became
unresponsive after what like six minutes
of him meeting him on the neck and then
one of the cops said I can't find
something something about not finding a
pulse and the dude kept his knee on his
neck for three minutes like two minutes
and 50 Thursday after after he lost his
pulse
yeah so the the medical examiner said
something like this isn't there was no
sign of traumatic asphyxiation or
strangulation okay but it was a
combination of his health affect his his
health issues and the restraint that
ultimately cost him his life and they
they added in the report that the cops
knew they were trained that this
position was dangerous those guys
getting locked up
but yeah man as you show so I'm trying
to finish the story about the journalist
I told them everything I have seen has
you know said to me that I think we're
heading towards what will end up being
terrifying racial tensions terrifying
like what I saw in in Milwaukee in 2018
I'm like I grew up in Chicago he's it's
the first time I've experienced
something like that and and the thing
for me is that like you know it's it's a
meme obviously I come from a mixed-race
family so I don't I don't get the
privileges among the the horrifying
racists you know white supremacist types
yeah and I don't get it among the social
justice I because I look too white so
it's like for me and my family it's run
high you know bunker down defend
yourself
but you there's no faction for for the
regular people so this is what scares me
when it start yelling these things I've
been I have friends who used to be lefty
and now they're right wing because
they're the same things happen to them
people screaming you know white swears
at them like you you white you know
effort and stuff like that and they're
like not even not even but it makes
people it it's just there and and that's
that's what freaks me out about seeing
my friend post this thing saying like
all white people now need to step up and
do these things I'm like that is a cult
and that's like yeah what do you think's
gonna happen do you think that when
they're screaming shoot the white people
that you get a magic pass is that why
you're doing it do they think that
they'll be the one saying like look at
the thing I posted please don't hurt me
and I'm not talking about black people
doing I'm talking about the social
justice and Tifa
lunatics which could include white
people as well yeah I don't know these
people could expect men but I don't know
dude I'm getting I'm getting all riled
up here like listen when we were
starting this show we were like oh look
Mark Zuckerberg is talking about this
and then the White House lockdown and
then the CNN stuff Atlanta we're like
whoa what's happening in Atlanta yeah
that's happening in Brooklyn right now
they're beatable they're beating people
who's beating people the cops pepper
spray nightsticks Lydia came in the room
is like we should do a light-hearted
episode yes yeah it's like she'd do a
light heart I'm over here like we were
like we got this a really great story
where a dude raised a couple hundred
like several hundred thousand dollars
his business back and get there and then
the White House gets locked down yeah
and then CNN gets bombed
and I was like whoa dude the White House
locked down does that happen recently
I don't know let me look it up so okay
um I want to read your super chats I
feel really bad because look it's a
combination of this is like there's a
lot of heavy piece of heavy stuff and
happening right now
yeah and it's getting were heavy man and
I'm hoping I'm hoping it just it rolls
away but it's Friday night and I I have
experience covering this stuff on the
ground not not only I've ever have I
covered multiple riots and protests and
events throughout the past decade I've
also been in other countries doing it as
well Adams been on the ground a couple
of times with me in some of these places
yeah and I know what happens on Friday
night I know what happens on Saturday
wild people people you know what's you
know what's contributing to all of this
is that one of the biggest factors
stopping mass explosions of rage and
violence is John's jobs
yup yeah the people busy nobody got him
anymore so this was just like The Keg
got lit yeah well yeah I'm telling you
man I know it's it's it's it's like a
cliche for Tim Poole to say it's gonna
benefit Trump but this is something I've
pointed out before that when anti foot
does this is what I said several years
ago when anti foot goes out and smashes
window starts fires burns things down
you know people do they say save us they
scream for help and when Trump stands up
and says I'm the one to do it
you think they'll pick Biden when their
buildings are being burned to the ground
they're gonna want that nasty nasty mean
dude they're gonna want all the boorish
bullying behavior from that man and they
don't want ya they're scared
people are what people so I don't know
how the truth is but I read that when
people get scared they vote Republican
because the Republicans are the Law &
Order candidates it's true security
military and strength order it's really
easy when you have the best economy ever
to be comfortable just say you know
orange man bad we want a soft
sophisticated president and then the
pandemic hits then your business is gone
now you're scared then all of a sudden
someone shows up and kicks the door in
so what do you do
defend yourself now you're getting
charged with murder you know I'd be
willing to bet Donald Trump would end up
you know ultimately defend that guy the
pawn shop or conservatives in general
are outraged so in so frozen our
familiar
a pawn shop owner in Minneapolis looter
breaks in shoots and kills him got
charged with murder we talked about the
other night because at first I'm kind of
like man maybe you should have fled but
think about it you're in a building
you're in your building
doors are locked outside fires burning
the city's burning down they're
screaming they're angry you don't want
to go outside what if you go out the
back door someone's breaking in maybe
his friends are waiting for you it's a
riot maybe you got the back door and
then someone catches you so what do you
do you defend your space what does the
government do murder charge so what what
do you do exactly
see I get it the government's saying
like we better charge him with murder
otherwise they're gonna write again it's
gonna get worse so what happens they
keep doing it
people are gonna defend themselves it's
gonna keep having it yeah so I hope come
Monday everybody wakes up and it's over
but this year has been a a senesce
collation endlessly just getting crazier
and crazier when the pandemic news first
first started it wasn't that big of a
deal for most people's like wow this is
crazy what's happening in China then it
hit us mm-hmm
then all of a sudden they said 15 days
slow the spread then it was two weeks
and I was extended extended extended now
it's months now it's months now in 90
days almost no is it past 90 I don't
even know they haven't even and now New
York New York don't care there now we're
locking done we got the data we don't
care we're locking down you know so the
protesters come out they don't care
about the lockdown imagine what it's
like if you are a family you know you
have a family you've done you've played
you've played by all the rules you said
okay we'll lock down all those
commercials where they're like we're
here we're with you together you've seen
those commercials like every single one
sing imagine you're one of those people
who fell for that and you lost your job
and you wrote you're running out of food
and you're saying if I just keep a smile
on my face in and hold you know hold on
through the night or all in this
together and then those people you
thought that were we're in this with you
threw a brick through your window and
burn your building down so no what does
that person do and and and I I know it
may be a bit hyperbolic but I got an
email from somebody in living in
Minneapolis being like I had to flee so
what happens when you when you follow
all these rules and then who's there for
you
buddy hmm the government have your back
they didn't they actually made it worse
when they went after when they when they
when they sparked this off yeah people
were looking for something to be mad
about they were mad they were depressed
to think about this man everybody who
was locked down lost their purpose yep
they lost their job they lost their
meaning if they even had one to begin
with that's a lot of a job is not enough
yeah some i mean sometimes it is
sometimes it is but a lot of times it
isn't so then to lose the job that was
barely keeping you in in saying it's
just sane you know and then you lose it
and then it's months go by and then you
have this Authority going you can't go
anywhere or else we're gonna arrest you
then you see it happening it's like man
I'll tell you when this happens it's not
surprising the feeling is like every day
the government has their hand over your
heart and they're slowly squeezing it
yeah you can feel that pain as
everything crumbles around you as you're
getting cabin fever a lot of people in
these big cities they're locked up in
cubical apartments and you can feel that
pain every day but you know if you just
wait eventually it will be okay and then
this happens with Floyd and then and
then this rage is anger you know is
focused hyper focused I could imagine
that man I can empathize that feeling
but I wished it wasn't as bad and then
the way the way I've been thinking about
it too is when we talk about these
left-wing protesters who garage is
burning stuff and riding mm-hmm part of
the social justice stuff has to do with
the fact that people have no purpose
anymore
yeah there-there was there four
questions raised about whether religion
is like something that humans need they
must have heads up he's going for it we
got a cat came in but let me let me
continue there's questions of whether or
not humans need religion because without
it they replace it with you know dogma
and they've replaced it with social
justice ideology and now it's like a
hollow shell of what religion was but if
you think about you know I've often
wondered about how things maintained
order in the past and and if everyone
agreed they were scared of the same God
you know they had a shared cultural
community and understanding
so it kept things calm in a lot of ways
but now we're at a point where no one
really agrees on their purpose and what
they're doing you know it's true and get
these young idealistic individuals and
they ask themselves why am i alive sorry
buddy I can't tell you I don't know
either I found I made my purpose you got
to make yourself you got a car of
yourself out of stone these people
didn't do that but then someone came
along and said I'd like to introduce you
to purpose and they presented them some
intersectional guidebook you know auntie
feh yeah had auntie if a handbook all of
a sudden now they found their purpose
you combine that with a lot of people
whose purpose was their jobs I wake up I
go to the office and that's my mission I
wake up I go to school that's my mission
and then you shut it all down for three
months and now they're sitting there
depressed suicides have gone up there's
like crazy stories about this and
they're questioning why are they even
here then George George Floyd gets gets
killed and they think to themselves this
is my purpose so they go out in these
massive crowds across the country and it
magnifies all of that social justice
outrage and this is what we get
you know night three crazier than I've
ever seen I'm hoping that it boils over
yeah but why isn't the lockdown lifted
certainly this the lockdown has been
voided right no one's caring anymore
cars are out there they're doing their
thing they're going to beaches nobody
cares seems like yeah your business
can't reopen is this what they want they
wanted their cities destroyed the crazy
thing to me is you can see it all it's
you can you can see it when they said
we're locking things down what have I
been saying what does everyone else been
saying we gotta reopen the economy this
businesses can't survive they're not
coming back
we don't care that's what they said we
don't care they just do not care
they said it without saying I think it
was Bill DeBlasio who literally said it
seriously
he said these businesses they can hold
off longer what was the exact quote I
don't know it was something like that
they can't you know they're gonna burn
the place to the ground because you
pushed him too far as I said businesses
in New York City we're already going
under because it's so expensive to run a
business in New York City
the rent is insane no matter where you
are if you're you want to be in any
relevant place it's expensive weight
incentive right three months like
alright your rents due now oh you don't
have it goodbye
yeah oh this Starbucks will will pay us
what that person's gonna do I wanna make
sure actual hair over I oh yeah what
would clarify what I was saying is I can
ago I think I misspoke I'm saying I hope
everything's simmers down
I said boil over right yeah yeah simmer
simmers down
yeah simmers down that's the right one
right yeah yeah I mean I mean blows over
ya know that's a good combination there
yeah we're gonna go to the go to the the
Winchester have a point we've heard all
the blow over where I'm not convinced
you know when the scary thing is we're
we're we got the China South China Sea
we got Iranian gunboats zigzagging
around our ships people you know we got
Venezuela trying to ram that vessel is
this it is this you know so I guess I
guess you know I think the important
thing to clarify we talk about Boogaloo
because it's popular right now in terms
of terminology you know the coming
second civil war civil war - you know
American Boogaloo no I'm talking about I
think I think collapse it's probably a
better way to put it but that's that's
depressing yeah the idea of a collapse
but it's accurate though I know it's
accurate but I like the sound of much
better well there's a difference though
ya know Boogaloo is is people fighting
like actively and then what happens is
the collapse the collapse can happen
whether or not we have a Boogaloo and
and that's what I feel is gonna happen
I feel like down I feels like the lock
down is over yeah you know but it feels
like even if we try to open up the
country's collapsing yeah we're
witnessing it right now yeah it's crazy
yeah so that someone come in just do we
get attacked like you know you know you
know that I guess it's a fake quote the
reason why Japan didn't invade America
is because there's a gun a rifle behind
every blade of grass apparently it was
attributed to Yamamoto of Japan but it's
like it's apocryphal disputed the sang
we don't know if it's true because we're
just looking the stuff up
how would you invade America if they
have a massive armed population wait
until everyone's at each other's throats
put like every right now put everyone at
each other's throats yep and have them
fight each other so you can sweep in the
only way what's that tell them about
identity politics yeah yeah introduce
them to identity politics where did that
all come from been a long time coming
some people think it's like a long con
from the Soviet Union Soviet era I don't
care about speculating I think the ideas
are kind of funny but man all I can
think is that tweet that I tweeted it
was that Hillary comment about cozying
up with China and I like how she's like
yeah well you know we should we should
cozy up with them we should ask them to
hack Trump's emails I was like right
what am i hearing right now it's like it
feels like they're kind of pawns she was
making a point about what Trump had said
sure cuz Trump said in the Russian verse
away right right right
absolutely yep of course and everyone
was like did she just break the law like
admiting yeah if they thought that was
illegal and that she did this but she
was trying to be that you know make this
like I don't hyperbolic point so here's
what I hope man I hope everybody has
taken care of yourself and your family
I'm not saying to go build a bunk or
anything like that actually you know
what let me stop right here let me stop
right here earlier this year when we saw
the pandemic coming yep and I did these
food promos I was like don't build a
bunker I just prepare you know have some
food I'm not talking about 30-year stock
I'm talking about like a little dry food
bucket now now I think it's actually
fair to say the Preppers were right I'm
not saying the world's gonna end but I'm
saying you see this stuff the White
House gets put on lockdown where does
that go next man the preppers Preppers
it cost America are going we're ready
for this yeah they literally are they
literally arts I met some and talked to
them when I was in Arizona oh yeah
that's right yeah last month mm-hmm know
this so this was three weeks ago we were
in Arizona we pull into this small town
no lockdowns burger joints open we walk
in this gas station they're serving
burgers no one's wearing any masks and
I'm like I'm wearing a mask and I'm like
what's going on here and I walk to buy
some you know some some coffees and I
asked I'm like nobody's wearing any
masks
oh no no we don't care and I was like
you're not worried about like this he
goes we're Preppers and I was like
really and she goes yeah she was like
you know how like all the toilet paper
got snatched up she's like my husband
looked at me and said we've enough
toilet paper and she laughed
she's like four Preppers she told her
husband that and they laughed she's like
we've got three months worth I got a lot
of I told you about the the old nuclear
silo in Jersey that's available right oh
really
just bring that up yeah that's
reinforced to withstand a nuclear
assault itself right build it up so how
many stories down I mean it would be
really cool to have like a subterranean
hangout of some sort yeah I don't really
think people need bunkers right now make
a crazy skatepark in the bottom of the
silo I'll tell you pretty cool I'll tell
you something mm-hmm I I think I'm
frequently correct I don't think I'm
always correct frequently frequently
correct and I tribute this to playing
chess since I was a little kid okay my
my mom taught me how to play chess like
I could play chess when I was before I
can't even remember being alive and not
knowing how to play jacks we should we
should play chess I was on the chess
team we play magic you know I mean
magics more fun now boom no we don't
play magic anymore it cuz broken man
alright the point the point is it taught
me planning ahead and calculating
multiple moves and variables and all the
stuff yeah and I grew up with that I
would say in my late teens I was
thinking about everything happening
around us and conflict and war and I
thought to myself it's impossible to
calculate every variable and it's harder
and harder to calculate variables as you
move further and further ahead so right
now I can say like what would happen if
I got up you know there's like 10
different potential things that could
happen you might say something she might
says and then after that if you then you
got to calculate all the next 10
variables so it's like exponentially oh
yeah so you can only go so far however
what I what I'm bringing up is that when
I was younger looking at everything
happening in the world and the media I
thought to myself that I felt like
around the time I was 35 everything was
gonna fall apart
mm-hm and now it's funny because I have
maintained like I've always I've always
thought to myself like I was like 19
years old and I'm like yeah
about probably the time I'm 35 is when
you know just for whatever reason that's
what I just felt like I could see I
could feel my gut that's approaching but
I may be wrong I'm just bringing it up
because it's something I've always had
in the back of my mind throughout my
entire life and as all of this stuff
happened from Occupy Wall Street
especially ten years ago I was like wow
and it's funny at the time I'm thinking
like maybe I had my timetables wrong
maybe the it falls apart and then
anything blows over and I'm like huh you
know I don't know and it was actually
crazy to me cuz then you know this year
starts new patrons happening and all the
protests off we saw before and I'm like
I'm gonna be 35 next year I'm 34 right
now is it it like is this is this gonna
fall apart it's gonna is this gonna go
nuts its trump gonna get reelected
triggering these far-left
to screech about some insanity or am I
just you know paranoid I don't know man
there's evidence the polls are shifting
stuff stuffs to happen that's crazy
earth earth is changing but I'll tell
you I'll tell you in front of our eyes
I'll tell you one one story that makes
me always trust my gut instinct
I was I was briefly staying on Fort
Carson near Colorado Springs okay I
think it's basically Colorado Springs
right and on my way back I was finally
back in Illinois because I'd gone to
visit my sister I'm driving in this is
in Glen Ellyn Illinois oh yeah I'm
driving Glen Ellyn so it's a little town
it is and I'm driving down Roosevelt
okay when I see a squad car behind me
and I'm thinking myself he's probably
under my plates like I'm probably get
pulled over and then he pulls up to my
right and then he speeds off and then
I'm like guess was nothing as I come up
this Ridge I see him pull into the left
lane and put his left signal on and I
thought to myself right that moment he's
like a few blocks in front of me I can
turn right right here and just go to the
store pick up some snacks
nah I'm being paranoid he wasn't run my
place I can pull me over he's turning
left guess what happened uh-huh pulled
you over right when I passed him he
flicked his lights on pulled me over
turns out so this was an illegal stop it
turns out that well arguably he ran my
plates and because I had got a
moving by I got a speeding ticket when I
wasn't speeding usually happened three
months prior about I was exiting on
Lakeshore Drive I mentioned this the
other day I think yeah and I was it's a
45 mile an hour speed limit I was
slowing down to get off and I got pulled
over you know and this cop walks up and
says you know you know I pulled you over
and I was like what no and he's like
you're speeding and I was like I wasn't
speeding it's like I don't care tell to
a judge sign here so I didn't know that
under the age of 21 if you get to move a
moving violations within three years
they instantly suspend your license I
thought I'm gonna go to court on this
one and I'm gonna say I didn't speed you
know and I'll fight it too you know
however I went to visit my sister
because her husband was overseas and you
know my family was like you know you're
not doing anything why don't you go hang
out with her for a little bit keep her
company was like okay sounds good I
realized that the the time limit was
running out and so my sister offered to
pay the ticket for me and not to worry
about it and I was like okay and as soon
as that button was clicked that was a
guilty plea which instantly suspended my
license did not know
oh so the cop pulls me over and he walks
right up to my window is in Glen Ellyn
again and he goes Tim Poole and I was
like yes and he goes you're under arrest
out of the car and I was like excuse me
is like license is suspended and I was
like what and he was like do you have
someone who can come pick you up I can
high bond you right now and you can
leave in the other court date and I was
just confused I was like I don't
understand why is my license suspended
he was like I don't know I don't care
and so there were some quite some
lawyers and they said what did he pull
you over for and I said nothing I wasn't
doing anything it's like oh so he
illegally stopped your vehicle the what
I was told was running a plate and
seeing a name and then sank seeing the
license suspended isn't a justification
for pulling a vehicle over because it
could be driven by somebody else okay
let's say you're driving my car to go
get milk and he pulls you over and goes
Tim point you go no as a legal stop once
he found out was me then the lawyer told
me you'll never win it's a waste of time
nobody cares so I end up having to
having to plead guilty what does this
have to just curious how what what would
why did you start bringing that up what
are you talking about I got instincts
okay when I saw that cop car and I knew
who's gonna pull me over and something
bad was about to happen and I could have
gotten off the road and gone to the
store like I wanted to but instead I
figure I'll keep driving human instincts
are powerful you know from that moment
on I've always said
whatever my gut tells me I'd go with
good yeah and so that's the story I
tried a little but that's the story and
that's why to wrap it back up to the
more stupid stuff is that I think it's
gonna get really really bad next year
mmm mmm that's what I've been thinking
for a long time that's what I'm betting
on thanks for checking out this clip
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you